moving on finally tonight i want to talk
about artificial intelligence or a.i
it's a technology which despite posing a
clear existential threat to humanity we
currently manage to keep under our
control using pictures of traffic lights
but make no mistake once the machines
learn how to recognize them we are all
[ __ ]
now i wanted to talk about ai because
there is a new popular trend that you
may have heard about
it seems like everyone is talking about
these websites that use artificial
intelligence to generate images
it's all because of a tool named dolly
which comes from a startup named openai
you type in a description of something
you want to see and a computer creates
realistic images to match the fun part
is you can be really elaborate with your
descriptions the system was trained with
650 million pictures and the results are
some of the best we've seen from
computers yet yeah ai image generators
there are a number of them out there now
like dali crayon and mid journey with
each one you simply type in a text
prompt and it will create images for you
in around a minute so for instance you
might type in let's say a roast beef
superhero now what does that look like
is it a superhero made of roast beef is
it a superhero that saves roast beef is
it both i have no idea but here's what
meat journeys ai created based on that
phrase and i have to say well played
robot
there's the fantastic roast beef
superhero logo the mild-mannered roast
beef hero with legs for arms and no
lower body the headless roast beef hero
holding a roast beef cane of justice and
the helmet-wearing america-shaped cut of
roast beef that appears to have taken a
[ __ ] on the floor
all four of those images are now my
favorite roast beef superheroes marvel
if you're watching there's phase five of
the mcu right there
it is genuinely fascinating not just to
see images come to life in seconds but
also to see how ai interprets these
prompts poking around on mid journeys
discord you'll discover things like this
delightful frog bumblebee or judy dench
fighting a centaur on the moon or what
the program decided to do when fed the
two-word prompt goose pilates which is
i think we could all agree
excellent
you you can kill an afternoon searching
to see what images others have requested
which is what one member of our staff
julia was doing when she made a fateful
decision because she started putting in
the names of various late-night hosts
like james corden which brought back
eight search results including james
corden flies a plane and trial cam
footage of james corden eating teeth and
i know it can be hard to see him do that
but there is one where he eats teeth
with paul mccartney and it's actually
very moving
interestingly for most hosts there
weren't a ton of results there were 14
for conan o'brien eight for colbert a
three apiece for trevor noah and jimmy
kimmel but here's where things got a
little bit weird because then she put in
my name and would you like to know how
many results came back it's 493.
and look on one level i get it i get it
i do have a face that's already
basically a boardwalk caricature
i've got what carnival artists refer to
as a real softball but nearly 500
results is a lot and it's not just the
volume it's the specificity of the props
there's john oliver in victorian era
dress john oliver bursting out of a can
of del monte green beans john oliver as
an amoeba viewed through a microscope
and john oliver commanding a hoard of
elves to charge a potato all of these
deserve to be in the louvre and at least
one of them depicts an actual nightmare
that i've had
but there is one mid-journey user who's
gone above and beyond a user by the name
of post poop zoomies hello i won't
pretend i loved saying those words but
i think you'll agree that their ai
creations are simply mind-blowing for
instance there's john oliver as mona
lisa which is striking though i believe
maybe enough to be prosecuted as a
felony in italy then there's john oliver
is a perfect egg and john oliver is an
egg with a bad attitude so don't mess
with him or he will do to you what he
did to humpty dumpty
that's that's just one of many images
where post poop zoomies seemingly tried
to tell a whole story there's also john
oliver at brunch with the girls and he's
laughing because debbie told a funny
joke which is remarkable because that's
exactly what i look like when debbie
does that
or how about john oliver as a cowboy
with a cowboy hat so large nobody has
any respect for him which is really
amazing because i could not tell you
what size a cowboy hat has to be to
instantly dissolve respect but that
computer was able to calculate the
dimensions perfectly and honestly bravo
to you post poop zoomies i did have some
questions about your process until i
found this post from you which read
simply i got high and blasted a million
john olivers
which definitely tracks
but the true masterpiece on mid-journey
is a long series of images i like to
think of as the cabbage saga created by
post-poop zoobees and another account
margaret
the story starts as all good stories do
humbly with the image of john oliver is
very confused
in a cabbage field from there we move to
john oliver growing cabbages in his
apartment a hobby that evidently takes
off for me given that we then see john
oliver gives a ted talk on proper
cabbage growth techniques which to be
fair is still better than this real ted
talk called how to tie your shoes
then things start escalating because
next we see john oliver throwing a
cabbage and john oliver throwing a
cabbage at a child for some reason and
then in a big plot twist john oliver
having dinner with a cabbage because he
realizes maybe he'd judge them too soon
that's a subtext that comes out of
absolutely nowhere but it makes much
more sense when you see john oliver
looking lovingly at his cabbage having
realized that he's falling in love
followed by does john oliver love the
cabbage yes yes he does and from there
it's on to inevitably john oliver and
the cabbage are getting married
and interestingly interestingly
it's at this point
that the ai for the very first time
seems to struggle with a prompt because
that seems to be an image of me getting
married to myself
and the cabbage somehow being there as a
witness but that's not what this story
is about is it and i don't know what
this computer is struggling to
understand about the very simple concept
of a man wanting to marry a cabbage
it's not complicated computer this is
why we're not letting you drive cars yet
but the story is still not done and i
have to warn you it takes something of a
darker turn because the next thing we
see is and this honestly made me gasp
out loud oh no john oliver dreamed about
being hungry and ate the cabbage in his
sleep
which is absolutely mortifying and
understandably followed by john oliver
crying into half a cabbage
and john oliver will never be happy
again his heart is broken but his
stomach is full
which is both tragic and somehow
beautiful
and if you're wondering what i did with
the other half of the cabbage that is
made clear by the final prompt which is
simply john oliver pouring cabbage ashes
into the ocean and what a journey we all
just went on
this story is a true testament to life's
highs and lows showing how poetic lovely
and weirdly full of cabbage life can be
there's really only one thing that
bothers me about all of this though and
that is that wedding image because take
a closer look at it right now the ai
program nailed all of its other
assignments but this image the key image
in the whole story the pivot point to
the tragedy that follows was somehow
beyond its capabilities which seems like
such a shame this story deserved better
post poop zoomies deserved better as did
margaret we all deserve better and
that's when it hit me there's really
only one way to remedy the fact that we
were cheated out of that key wedding
image and that is for me to provide it
for you now but not not through graphics
no that would be far too easy i'm
thinking more of a full vibrant tableau
that brings it
that brings it all home so please come
with me because i'm about to marry a
[ __ ] cabbage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you john
take this cabbage to be your lawfully
wedded spouse
to have and to hold from this day
forward in sickness
and in health
until death do you part i do steve
and do you promise not to eat it in your
sleep
i'll try my very best but i think we
both know what might well
happen okay
by the powers vested in me i now
pronounce you
man and cabbage
you may kiss the cabbage
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no not again
you